People just don't shop
at places like ours anymore.
Yes, it's the same with us.
Why not? Your blades are top-notch, pops.
People can find everything they need
at shopping malls.
It might be time.
We can't stand by
while our turf's being laid to waste!
Tatsu, what are you planning?!
THUD
I may not look it,
but I dabbled in some street selling
in the past.
Gather round, gather round!
If you're not in a rush,
come over and have a listen!
What? What's this?
What's going on?
Some product demo?
Lo and behold, the all-purpose knife!
Made in Japan,
theland of pristine soil and seas!
This steel is on another level
to anything else!
Is it just another dull knife
where only the tip can cut?
Or can it even slice solid bamboo?!
It won't bend! It won't warp!
All this and it didn't even
blunt the blade!